[Music]
lad Bible with Billy Eilish
and I am going to be guessing what
happens next let's go home boys about to
drop his phone we already know what's
about to go down
the guy drops his phone into his own
urine the men all start singing I want
it that way by the Backstreet Boys pitch
bro the guy on his phone does an
incredible impression of Donald Trump D
none of the above
it's for sure the guy dropped his phone
I don't ever know what else it could be
[Applause]
and it's one of those ones on the floor
where all the pee goes and has an orgy
[Music]
is this to two-putt to do this Portugal
hey the chicken has stolen valuables
from the house be the chicken lets out a
noise like an old lady see the chicken
has been looking after a group of
kittens D none of the above I really
want it to be a chicken has been looking
after a group of kittens I really would
like that to be the answer but I'm gonna
say
that's okay
see that's what I wanted to see Oh also
we're not gonna watch a video I just
have to guess what's in the bed a a
snake I would love to see a bird I'm
gonna say something cuz that's what I
hope it's if the screen was fire oh wow
okay the guy slaps the camera with a bag
of Doritos the guy shakes hands with his
fingers bent the wrong way around my guy
shakes hands with his foot well we know
he has Doritos I don't even know how
that's funny boy this one's sick
I know dude this dude is all me yes I
can bend my back like an insane person
like it's crazy I used to like when I
was younger I thought it was so funny
that I could fart on my own head and the
chickens mother flies in and attacks the
man be the chicken on the man's shoulder
I hear that one see the chicken leaps up
and falls down the back of the sofa
his face tells how cute that but it does
look like the chicken the little chick
is is like raring to fly I'm gonna say
that because I it looks like it's trying
to leave it looks like it's about to
jump see it's so wet ah oh this is the
last one time to give you a punch take
yeah
okay the kid fly kicks his dad across
the face the kid tries to throw
something at his dad but hits the D see
his sister runs in and takes out dad for
her brother Dean are they both I love
little kids oh my god I think Oh fire
yes whoo she got his ass I'm Billy
and that was what happens next uh-huh I
try sets pink y'all really put me in
front of a pink background whoo whoa
okay
nice